[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Every organization
would like their API program
to be successful.
Quality assurance strategy is
about detecting and correcting
problems during the SDLC
to ensure APIs are reliable
and consumers can
utilize them to deliver
high-quality
digital experiences.
Let's look at the digital
value chain again.
Consider where quality
assurance should be implemented.
In most organizations,
we quickly
identify the technical areas.
Your back-end servers and
APIs must be clear of defects
to ensure you are
generating great and quality
digital experiences.
However, focusing solely on
protecting code integrity
is only the start of a
quality assurance strategy.
Your team should
actively participate
and have a culture of continuous
quality assurance as well.
Developers and key team
members must consistently
strive to find, prevent,
and correct issues.
Quality assurance should also be
an active process in deploying
your connected experiences.
This can be automated through
a continuous integration
and delivery tools
that could also
help with unit testing,
integration testing,
and performance testing.
The principle of
automation and quality
is an essential part of
digital transformation.
CI/CD often helps reduce
rework and technical debt,
while maintaining quality
throughout the entire
development lifecycle.
Some of the benefits of CI/CD,
with the help of automation,
include increasing the
speed of finding and fixing
code and integration
errors, decrease
in the cost of finding
and fixing those errors,
increase in dev team's
confidence in code stability,
frequency in releasing
the code to production.
But successful quality
assurance strategies
must also occur at
the customer level.
Leveraging your customers
to receive feedback, test
new features and services,
and validate user experiences
must be an integral part of your
continuous improvement process
and ensure that your
organization is able to keep
your customers happy.
Let's take a look at the details
within quality assurance.
Here are a few
factors to consider
when building your quality
assurance strategy.
Reducing risks is critical
in your QA strategy.
The risk of a bad experience
reaching the customer
can be greatly reduced
when regression testing
and continuous quality
assurance is in place.
Be sure that your
team understands
what the objectives,
requirements, and acceptance
criteria are for new features
and changes to your APIs.
The key is to make sure your
requirements are clearly
aligned with your business needs
and stakeholders' expectations.
Does your team have the right
technical skills and capacity
to ensure quality
assurance is being met?
As testing becomes
increasingly automated,
QA engineers are replacing
manual testing efforts.
Your API team and
testers should automation
testing and QA skills
as well as understanding
of the key test frameworks
in the development cycle.
Understand how
your products work
and how the tools
can be used to help
maintain your quality assurance.
Each tool in your CI/CD process,
along with your API platform,
can be leveraged in
your QA strategies.
The business must
support a culture
of quality assurance and
continuous improvement as well.
This means including QA further
upstream in the requirements
and design process
and also collaboration
between the product on the QA
to mutually define acceptance
criteria and test cases.
Finally, also consider any
organizational regulations
that are required.
These may also drive quality and
may require specific standards
to satisfy feature release.
Having your
regulations understood
by everyone on your team
will prevent needless cycles
to approve new features.
So let's summarize everything
with a few key strategies
to build quality into your SDLC.
The first is to
make time to test.
Unfortunately, some teams often
look to QA as an afterthought.
Only when something breaks
does the question come up,
where was our quality assurance?
Have dedicated time and QA role
embedded in your daily routine
to test your APIs
and validate quality.
Second, everyone is
responsible for quality.
As we discussed
earlier, everyone
is responsible throughout
your digital value chain
and software
development lifecycle
to test, detect, prevent,
and correct issues.
Do not hand off QA
to someone else.
Follow through on every issue.
Third, documentation
is essential.
The more your team gets
comfortable with documenting
product features
and product issues,
the better your
quality will get.
This should happen every layer
of your experiences, back-end,
front-end, and APIs.
We discussed Gherkin
as a great way
to document both the
requirements and a test
scenario at one time.
This smart way of writing
saves a ton of team time
and helps enable
everyone to weigh in.
Furthermore, Gherkin can
be converted directly
into programmatic test
scripts, saving even more time.
Fourth, automate testing but
don't avoid manual testing.
We discussed on
your CI/CD pipeline
can assist in quality
assurance processes
by standardized testing,
deployment, and integration.
But don't solely rely
on automated testing.
Your team should
always get involved
and conduct manual tests
to validate the automated
testing is working properly.
Fifth, test early and often.
Quality is about consistently
delivering quality experiences.
Your code, designed APIs,
and user experiences
should constantly be
reviewed and supported
to ensure continuous
quality assurance.
Testing in each sprint right
after code is developed
is a great way to catch bugs
before they are a larger
impact.
Oftentimes, the QA
and the developer
will sit side by side together
at the end of their sprint
to do a QA walkthrough.
If something's
found, the developer
will fix it on the spot,
and no defect ticket even
needs to be logged.
Finally, and sixth, include
your customers in the process.
Your customers are and
developer community
can help ensure quality.
Invite them to a user testing
at the end of the sprint
or have them play with an alpha
or beta version of your APIs.
Building a pilot
customer group can be one
of your most valuable assets.
Listen to what they have to say
and issues they report to you.
Everyone should be involved
with the quality assurance.
Hopefully, you've found a few
strategies in the presentation
to help build a successful
quality assurance
strategy to support your
APIs and ongoing development
and customer experiences.
If you want more
information, check out
the community for
ebooks, articles,
and other related topics.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]